[Music]
do you guys think that we are in
a simulation yes i didn't even finish it
and you already knew it was
i knew stimulation stimulation i'm in a
stimulation
yeah he's like okay not right now not
right now it's okay that's what the
concept is right like if you if you see
deja vu it's because it's like a
chip in the that's what the matrix or
the mandela effect and all that
oh you know it because you're on
tick-tock i'm on tick-tock i love being
on this like
tick-tock uh threat or like if you like
i like a video and then you continue
seeing it yeah i love being in that and
then the ufo stuff
all that conspiracy stuff oh [ __ ] that's
on tick tock
everything's on tv the category
people dancing all the time that's
that's that that's one algorithm that's
so many that's because you keep liking
the dancing videos you gotta stop liking
those videos
they're really really good dude honestly
seeing all this content come out of tick
tock i'm like [ __ ] am i gonna have to
re-download this [ __ ] app how come
people watch the same dance
a bunch of different with a bunch of
different people doing the same exact
one i don't know they like it
that's weird huh your algorithm's weird
yeah you explain it
i don't know just search because they
jiggle differently
oh that could be one they're like
teenagers man
i'm not looking at the teenagers i'm
looking at the legal ones thank you very
much
above 30. everybody can jiggle really
we're moving away from that conversation
going back to this uh
simulation i wasn't stimulation
simulation
so have you guys had weird instances
where you're like wait that was [ __ ]
weird
like the universe glitched a little bit
impossible so have you guys had
weird instances where you're like wait
that was [ __ ] weird like the universe
glitched a little bit
i'm so [ __ ] weird that i'm like
there's no [ __ ] way
that i'm plugged into a battery or like
someone created me to be like some sort
of battery or someone created me because
if
i was a creation of someone else that
person is
even [ __ ] what if it wasn't a person
what if it was an algorithm that created
us
impossible you know how [ __ ] weird i
am i
second that you're [ __ ] weird that's
that's what makes me believe we're in a
simulation because you're so weird no
the algorithm is broken
if they created me you alone make me
believe that we're in a simulation
really yeah cause you're the outlier for
us you're the glitch
we're like everything's pretty normal
but then but this bark is [ __ ] weird
oh maybe that one glitch broke his brain
i'm the i'm the one that makes it to
ross the irregular pants with one pant
leg long on the other
hand everything else makes it to
nordstrom's yep exactly that makes sense
then
simulation glitches tick tock if you're
on sick dog you know this video
but this video went viral recently and
you guys tell me
what what's your theories around this
okay you tell me what could this
possibly be
i'll tell you what happened okay i
literally can't make this [ __ ] up
at first i was just sitting here i was
like maybe it's where i'm sitting
because like
my diffuser nothing's coming out of it
but in the mirror
stuff is coming out of it so i get up
close to it
dude look there's nothing coming out of
that
but in the mirror that's
trippy
that's crazy that just means that it's
on and the reflection
can maybe i don't want to make it too
boring
let's go let's let's come up with the
ideas no so a lot of people were saying
that
they were like or not a lot but some
people were saying well yeah maybe
because of the angle that you're in
you just can't see the steam uh where
you are but you can see it through the
mirror because the light's hitting in a
different different way yeah
but she even made it a point to like
stand up and look from look at it closer
or whatever like
get a different angle so i don't know
this is like filming a hot road
and being like look it's [ __ ]
jiggling dude
[Laughter]
look at it it's [ __ ] jiggling all
over but then when i go up to the road
in the front of it it's solid as [ __ ]
that mirror is a portal
that's what everyone's saying the other
dimension yeah and she has the special
mirror
that you can see she should film herself
trying to go through the portal
i think she walked through the mirror
yeah or see her
other side so that's what there's there
was the top comment there
saying um and the girl in the in the
other dimension
is filming a tick tock on how there's no
steam coming out from the mirror's
reflection
you know what's not that weird seeing
steam coming out of a diffuser
it'd be weird if it was like a plant
with [ __ ] steam coming out of it i'd
be like whoa that's
got the glitch in the system right there
definitely a glitch
but seeing steam coming out of a
diffuser did you guys see it as a
diffuser is that a human
humidifier yeah it's like a remote
aromatherapy like you put like
chamomile or lavender oh that's nice did
you guys see the tick tock where there's
a plane
that looked like it was just floating in
the air like not flying
no no because that one looked crazy too
so the person is driving
or and there's a passenger filming and
usually like the plan would go this way
right but as the car was going this way
the plane is flying backwards with the
car what i don't think i've seen that
yeah that's crazy that's another glitch
i don't know we need neil degrasse tyson
explain all these things yeah
he would just sit here and laugh at us
and cause dumb [ __ ] the whole time he
explains it in a smart way that i feel
like oh
i see yeah i just want it to make sense
stephen no i know i know
you make sense i just find it funny that
he would find us all so stupid as well
that's okay i could be stupid i just
wanted to make sense yeah so what's the
real answer it's not just that the light
make it make sense but science doesn't
know bart make it make sense
they looked it up and they don't know
people are like have you guys heard of
photoshop hello
back too yeah i mean definitely this
chick could be
really savvy and video it's a deep fake
with steam
yeah deep fakes deep faking the steam
who knows
there's a leprechaun on inside of the
mirror going
that's the only that's the only answer
there was another comment too
uh on her tic talk that said girl i'm a
witch and you need to close that portal
draw pentagrams on each corner of the
mirror to close that portals
there's a boiling cat in the diffuser
and she's like ps [ __ ] vampires
it's like oh why i didn't know there was
a
like a battle going on between the two
which is in vampires
you just made it up oh no azalea was
going hard on vampires the other day and
i was just like damn dude
oh because it's it's vampires and
werewolves yeah so
that's the beast so the witch is okay
historical beef but what about zombies
do everyone just hate zombies everyone
hates zombies so zombies like yeah [ __ ]
all of these guys
i don't think they exist but but but
we're all we are
zombies too i mean vampires in the world
for sure exist
oh they're real okay yeah i don't think
zombies are just make believe
i think so well what about the santa
cruz like who's santa
with is he with the vampire santa's with
the elves yeah okay and the reindeers
that can fly okay from the north
man i wish i knew someone magical that
could teach me all this [ __ ]
where's the leprechaun fit in all this
um
yeah i thought they just kick you with
the cereal people
i think that's what it is like tony the
tiger and toucan sam
all right [ __ ] tricks
does count chocula hang with the cereal
people or the vampires oh
he gets to choose maybe we need we need
to get experts here
can we get a cereal expert and then we
get a serial killer by accident i know
right i'm a cereal sorry wrong cereal
maybe hangs out with the count from
sesame
street it's all those entertainment
vampires if only we had an expert
show you know someone where we bring in
an expert and we talk
oh i know bunjo on this channel
have a new segment on this channel yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i was trying to
introduce
she tried to set you up for it and you
[ __ ] i didn't hear it i didn't care
what she couldn't handle the moment
i didn't hear what she was saying yeah
he didn't hear me
yeah that's true we could do it here
it's going to be so good
we could have dinosaurs we could have
cereals
we'll have all kinds of people if you
guys are an expert
on anything because i know like in the
comments we have a lot of [ __ ]
experts
we could have y'all a part of this show
just hit us up
you have to have credentials though you
can't just be this type of self
this time yeah yeah we found out about
it
we found out about that you need to find
out about credentials actually yeah so
we're
we're on to that real quick credentials
we're gonna do a real check
we found out that you need degrees and
[ __ ] actually we know about that stuff
now
yeah you can't just print it out nope
you can't just print out degrees and
[ __ ] tell us that they're degrees
no yeah it's not gonna work i i i'll see
you right there we're on to that now i
know
we started googling things even if it's
like embarrassed
like with something well that's legit
that's pretty legit
yeah we've worked with people that know
how to print out their own badges and
stuff so you gotta
you gotta get the real stuff they're
tricky what i'm saying yeah like the
embossing thing is just a flower and
you're like
this is legit it's a buzz what's in boz
it's when you it's raised like it's a
stamp but then like it's just
oh like you melt the thing and you smack
it like your diplomas the certificate
you know that golden foil and it's like
bumpy
the sticker right yeah but then it's
bumpy that's embossed
because it creates the texture i see i
don't think he gets it
but a seal i understand seals so i'll go
with that
nice are there people are there experts
on the ai simulation thing
well isn't it i would assume so the
experts on the
the world is the simulation yeah like on
the theory
like there's like actual legit theories
who like go into the details about it
like i know
elon musk is pretty big on that they
make their primary income
from studying the world that is yeah
probably not huh
i thought it was a uh it's a it's within
quantum physics
i thought it was in that area but i
don't know that realm
well isn't it the whole thing about like
it's
there's more evidence that we are in a
simulation than
that we're not who said that judge judy
yep
yo if it's just judy man believe her
well i've heard that they
they've been unable to rule it out right
yeah wow
i mean i assume it's the same logic as
religion where people are like
we can't prove there is no god
so there's a god i still i
assume it's the same idea i mean i know
we've had this conversation in the past
but i'm gonna ask again like how
if if we were to find out that we really
weren't a simulation like
would you want to go check out real
world or would you just be like
[ __ ] it i think i would ask first i'm
like how's the real world what's it like
that's what neo didn't do huh before you
took the pill or truman
yeah truman didn't ask i was like why
are you not asking he just left
but that's because he's he was horny
he was very horny you remember at the
end
he's like i gotta get my girl dude i
forgot
and then she was on the tv going yes get
out of there
come [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] so he was
motivated by that
that's true because he had no well he
did they get
they gave her him a girlfriend on the
show yeah a wife he had a wife
he didn't want her did she [ __ ] him on
do you think that they thought i don't
know it's pretty
intense it was all acting method acting
you think if you were in the matrix and
then you woke up from it and then you
were like this place sucks you just plug
yourself back in
that's what what's his name wanted to do
yeah he wanted to snow pants uh-huh
remember steak eating guy oh that steak
looks so good joe pantoliano i'd rather
stay here this is cool
that's what i'm saying i'm like what or
what if outside is really dope
the scenario is you don't get to find
out until you unplugging you can't go
back
i just stay here i'd stay here maybe
that's what heaven is
they go it's and you're like oh
i hate this [ __ ] what
i'm around all these people that just
follow the rules and like
oh i hate this i've never heard this
interpretation of heaven i like it
what do you do you go hey give me a gun
you try to blow your brains out see if
you go somewhere else
oh yeah yeah like inception you just
like
you die you go to another dude but
probably in heaven your [ __ ] glitter
comes out or something
oh you can't even kill yourself i bet no
dude think about it the people that get
into heaven glitter does
well how did lucifer go to hell there's
another way to get out of there well he
got sent there by god
what did he do just do the same thing he
wasn't bad he betrayed god or some [ __ ]
let's be so bad in heaven
and god bless you go get out of here
you're literally saying you want to go
to hell no i just want to
explore that's true how would you know
if hell's better because like if all of
my friends are going to hell
and then i'm in heaven and it's just a
bunch of strangers
and i'm just like man these guys are
lame i can't even talk about things with
them because
they're so like like you know square so
you're the guy who your mom goes if all
your friends want to go to hell you go
and you're like yeah that's where my
friends are going
it's gonna be a party down there yeah
you